and its simplest evolve is a hardcore
game of hide-and-go-seek and for anyone
who's ever played that game in the real
world where you play it makes all the
difference in how fun it is the level
isn't evolved have to account for hiding
tracking and fighting your prey as well
as dealing with the various ways that
creature or hunter can traverse the
environment and all that has to be
wrapped up in an alien world that proves
to be as dangerous as anything else in
the game
obviously a lot of attention has to be
considered to like how a map works and
how it sort of maintains the fun but
when you have varying traversal methods
be a monster or the jetpacks of the
hunters and the fact that there's really
two stages of the game one which is more
like a hide-and-go-seek you're trying to
stay away from each other and one which
is you're sort of combat how did you
have to rethink approaching level design
we didn't know what would work and what
would be fun so we really were starting
at zero we have a number of level
designers and we really didn't want to
sort of set any guidelines for like how
big should the mat be or how wide or
what the flow should be we just really
wanted to not put rules on anybody and
just let everybody kind of explore
there's a bunch of maps that we tried
that won't ship with the game but we
learned from those the first map that we
did was enormous well it was like a
little over half a kilometer and we
found very quickly that if a Maps too
big they never find each other and if I
mapped too small they can't get away
from each other right so there's a sort
of fine balance you know that it really
can only be figured out through playing
that map over and over and over again
you know how big a map needs to be and
then obviously the aesthetics of it have
to then work within this sort of
fantastic world say you know a more
traditional shooter you know you're
using kind of real-world locations but
here you had to kind of make it work if
I'm a wild place just speaking of you
know the art side yeah because it's an
alien planet right you don't really
expect it to look just like Earth you
know so initially we made all of our
trees really weird you know that looked
pretty much nothing like you ever see on
earth and the odd thing that we found
was that it made you uncomfortable to be
either like you know we would have
people say is that going to attack me
they weren't sure what the rules were
and so you know then that's where we
started pushing it back towards a more
earth-like environment right because
that's comfortable right people
immediately understand that hey I'm in a
forest and there are a certain set of
rules that you know you apply to a
forest it's not really like any forest
on earth but it's close so I get it
another aspect sort of movement you know
once you do start engaging with the
other side that doesn't mean you want to
do that in perpetuity for the rest of
the match that there is a desire to want
to escape yeah a forest environment was
the first environment we built we have
these tall trees but trees don't break
your line of sight down low where the
players eye is so we had to start making
these really large bushes and that
worked and we started building maps that
way we said okay we figured it out and
then we went to go build desert desert
doesn't have a lot of trees and bushes
and yes we can use rocks but you can
only use so many rocks before the map
starts to look weird so the other thing
was out the two changes you know we can
have some small Maps as long as there
are different levels you know I can be
10 feet from the monster but he could be
on a Ledge that's 20 feet above me and I
don't notice him and the terrain there's
never a flat spot in the terrain and
that just caused all kinds of problems
you know anything from animations from a
four-legged animal on uneven terrain and
now you're looking at I case systems to
snap the feet to the uneven terrain are
you looking at does he tilt when he goes
up and down and then monsters our
monsters climbed they can climb almost
anything right so the climbing has to be
able to handle an organic surface you
know it's like one thing on the art side
to want these really natural-looking
organic environments and then on the
tech side you've actually got to go back
and make all that stuff work
in terms of locations you know you sort
of desert locations you have swampy
locations you have some that actually
have two different weather patterns that
are going on simultaneously it's kind of
like it helps inform the fiction of the
world did you guys talk a bit about the
whys of the location and how it fit into
the overall I guess narrative you know
we really wanted the world to have that
feeling of kind of isolation so
immediately that's like okay well it's a
colony planet that's why it's relatively
unpopulated because you're on the
farthest reaches of civilized space and
you know it's so immediately you have
that feeling of like there's no way off
this planet the other thing is like
we've always really liked westerns so
why not you know inject a little bit of
that flavor and I think as you run
around the world you see little bits of
that Old West architecture that kind of
harkens back to those days monsters and
hunters on this map there is the flora
and fauna you know there's there's a lot
of creature something which are
completely harmless to a hunter so which
are incredibly harmful I mean I the the
tyrant is the one where you know if I
saw water on a handful of maps well
there's certainly for the monster we
wanted there to be this element of risk
reward for when he's eating right so you
know the bigger the more dangerous a
creature is the more new the faster he
gets to Evan right exactly yeah the more
sustenance he he gets from that so
there's this whole strategizing though I
want to stay safe and just eat the
little creatures that aren't gonna hit
me or you know what do I want to stage
up quicker
the wildlife creates opportunities for
both teams we saw a monster win a game
because three hunters two of them
stepped in plants and one got hit by a
megamouth all in the same time the whole
team got taken out by the environment
you know from where you started with the
game and you know those initial levels
have you guys learned more about the
vagaries and the nuances of level design
because you've been trying to do
something that pretty much has to be
done before yeah I think so you know
we're still learning more and we expect
to learn more once we get more players
in there we study heat maps and all the
places where people fight and where
people killed and how do they move
through the maps and so we feel like
we've learned a lot but we still feel
like there's a lot more to come like
there's a lot more to learn we know that
we can make even cooler stuff in the
future so we're just gonna keep pushing
the signature element of the vault is
the monster what did you know though
going in which had to do a to have an
exciting monster and one that would be
competitive inside of the game
environment from a visual standpoint I
think the initial goal was to come up
with monsters that you'd never seen
before
right and so what we ended up with were
some monsters as works of art were
really cool but you would look at them
and you didn't know what the hell you
were looking you want to be attached to
your character who monsters are no
different certainly when I'm playing as
the monster I feel like I'm the good guy
and they're the bad guys and of course
vice versa
you